night and israel has more with them bam
you're coming off of a west coast trip
that came
ended with a few straight losses you
don't have jimmy butler jimmy called the
team
soft and then you come out have this
performance and that game winner in
front of a crowd what does that feel
like
man uh i wanted to stand up on the table
like d-wade but
not not today um you know great moment
you know i felt like the team wanted me
to want it in my hand so
you know i made a big shot man you know
i thank god
i thank all the people for my support
and uh these fans man it's good to have
him in the building man so
you came out with a doug a lot of people
have been asking you are saying that you
should do more offensively obviously
with jimmy out it's something that you
would look to do
how much have you looked toward
increasing your offense while also
finding that balance with keeping the
offense flow going
uh you know it's a it's a new uh
it's a new spot for me so you know i'm
just trying to pick my spots and uh jb
has been working with me
you know uh and i made shots today so uh
great great performance great
performance for my team man we need to
build off of this
bam there's a lot of people in this
building today the heat of an increasing
capacity responsibly what does that feel
like coming in off this road trip
man did you hit arena you hear him after
that shot
um you know it's just great to have him
in here man so
we're going to enjoy with us enjoy this
one and get back to it tomorrow
thank you bam mark thank you back to it
tomorrow
they call it heat culture down here
folks will have a monday